今天想跟大家聊一個我覺得很有意思的案例，它跟紐約市的電網有關，但我覺得對我們很多台灣中小企業主或上班族來說，會很有啟發。
紐約電網？聽起來有點遙遠，怎麼說呢？通常這些大型基礎建設的案子，跟一般小公司或我們上班族能做的，中間隔著一道很深的鴻溝吧。
不，這就是它特別的地方。紐約市在建大型儲能設施的時候，會遇到非常多的法規障礙，還有民眾對電池火災的疑慮。簡單說，要裝大型電池很難。
嗯，大型基礎建設卡關很常見。那這些公司是怎麼做的？找關係疏通嗎？還是直接繞過？
他們沒有硬碰硬。他們換個思路，把大型的電池拆成很多小型的，分散佈署到意想不到的地方，像什麼感應爐、食物推車、電動自行車。
等等，這裡我有疑問。你說分散式電池，這樣成本不會更高嗎？每一顆都小小的，管理起來也很麻煩，能達到大型儲能的效果嗎？
其實這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。像一家叫 PopWheels 的公司，他們為送貨員的電動自行車提供換電服務。他們在紐約市設了約 50 個換電櫃，流通著大約 2,500 顆電池。
喔，所以是靠數量累積。但這跟電網有什麼關係？這些電池只是給電動自行車用吧？
PopWheels 最近開始把電池提供給食物推車業者，讓他們能取代原本的燃氣發電機。大概四顆電池就能提供五度電，足夠推車一天的營運。
這個做法很有意思。把原本用在移動載具的電池，延伸到其他小型商業應用，減少排放，這倒是不錯。但這對電網的整體穩定性，幫助真的很大嗎？
另一家公司 Copper，他們直接把電池整合到感應爐裡。這樣就算停電，住戶也能煮飯。而且更重要的是，當爐子在使用時，電池能提供部分電力，幫住戶省下昂貴的電氣升級費用。
這就比較接近電網的概念了。直接在終端設備上做手腳，減少對電網瞬間高負載的需求。但每家都這樣做，真的能產生大規模的影響嗎？這模式撐得久嗎？
像 David Energy 的共同創辦人兼執行長 James McGinniss 就說了，這可能是過去 20 年來電網領域最大的變化。Copper 的共同創辦人 Sam Calisch 也提到，如果美國每台爐子都內建電池，加起來可以達到數十吉瓦的電力。
數十吉瓦？那確實是個驚人的數字，我猜啦，這就是他們能繞過大型法規，直接在用戶端創造價值的關鍵。不需要大規模審批，插上電就能用。
沒錯，原文就說了，因為這些電池小，甚至整合在其他設備裡，通常不需要大規模的電網升級或複雜的許可流程。就像陽台太陽能板一樣，插上電就能減少能源消耗。
嗯，所以他們是把「大型、集中」的思維，轉變成「小型、分散」的策略。那如果我們是創業者或公司主管，可以從中學到什麼？
我覺得最關鍵的啟發，就是在面對巨大障礙時，不要只想著硬碰硬。像物流業，如果租大型倉庫很貴，能不能考慮小型倉庫或流動倉庫？服務據點也是，不一定要大店面，小而美的分散式服務點會不會更靈活？
我是這麼想的，這點其實不容易做到。你必須先看清問題的本質，像他們不是要「建大電池」，而是要「提供穩定電力」。一旦目標明確，解決方案就能多元化。
對，而且他們也提供了多重價值。像食物推車，不只提供電力，還減少空污；感應爐不只停電能用，還能省電費。這點很重要，讓消費者有感。
那一般上班族可以把這個概念帶入自己的工作或生活嗎？感覺有點難連結。
其實可以。比如說，很多專案會卡在「沒有足夠人力」或「沒有足夠資源」這種大型障礙。我們能不能把一個大專案拆解成許多小任務，分配給不同部門或甚至外包，讓每個小環節都能獨立運作，最後再彙整起來？
你是說，化整為零的思維。就像與其去爭一個大辦公室，不如把工作拆解成遠距與實體結合，更有效率。
沒錯，或是面對一個很複雜的報告，與其一個人埋頭苦寫，能不能拆解成不同部分，讓同事們各自負責擅長的領域，最後再整合，這樣可能比一個人撐著更容易完成。
總結來說，這案例提醒我們，當傳統的大型模式遇到瓶頸時，或許跳脫框架，從分散式、小規模、多功能的角度去思考，反而能找到出乎意料的解決方案。
嗯，好像也提醒了我們，有時候，小的累積也能成就大的改變。